et nous sommes en ligne à présent avec
cécile coup de rio bonjour merci
beaucoup de nous rejoindre sur l'antenne
de france 24 vous êtes la présidente
d'amnesty international france
le haut commissariat aux réfugiés dit
craindre que 5 millions d'ukrainiens
soit du pull déplacer et suite à ce
conflit en ukraine sur une population
totale d'un peu plus de 40 millions de
personnes c'est une situation d'urgence
hommes absolue selon vous tout à fait
d'urgence et absolue et effectivement on
peut comprendre que des personnes fuient
une guerre qui en particulier cible
largement les civils donc il est
important pour nous de rappeler à
l'union européenne d'organiser un
accueil rapide efficace d'abandonner
toute exigence concernant les visas car
l'urgence absolue est de protéger ces
personnes et je précise aussi de les
protéger quelle que soit leur couleur de
peau ou la nationalité car évidemment
nous avons accueilli avec avec joie le
fait qu'il y ait un élan je l'arrêté de
des pays frontaliers et 1 accueillent
des ukrainiens avec vraiment un élan
solidarité nous avons en revanche eu des
remontées d'informations selon
lesquelles des personnes en fonction de
leur couleur de peau avait été refoulé
ou empêchés de passer la frontière donc
évidemment nous appelons en cela ce gars
était totale il avait de tous les
réfugiés
quel est pour vous l'urgence on était
tout à l'heure en ligne avec raphaël
pythie qui nous disaient craindre que
kiev la capitale ukrainienne soit
assiégé par les forces russes et que la
population que les civils qui sont
encore dans kiev ne soit
réduit à à la fin et au froid la france
va essayer tout à l'heure aux nations
unies de plaider pour des corridors
humanitaires c'est ça qu'il faut mettre
en place tout à fait utile dans les
corridors humanitaires coûtent
absolument nécessaire dans le situation
il faut à la fois faire preuve de
beaucoup d'efficacité de rapidité dans
l'accueil la production internationale
mais sur place il faut également pouvoir
apporter une aide humanitaire en termes
de soins de nourriture et donc c'est
absolument une priorité également pour
nous et puis dans un second temps nous
demandons également le européenne
d'organiser un accueil qui se voit dans
une meilleure répartition car pour
l'instant bien évidemment ce sont les
premiers pays frontaliers qui a que ces
personnes aient tant mieux il faut
également que l'union européenne dans
son ensemble vote jeudi c'est une
protection internationale à toutes les
personnes qui sont actuellement sous les
bombes et sous cette attaque de la
russie très concrètement que se
passe-t-il pour les dizaines de milliers
de civils qui se trouve en ce moment en
pologne ils n'ont ils ne vont sans doute
pas rester dans la zone frontalière
qu'est ce qui va leur arriver dans un
premier temps effectivement que nous
saluons l'accueil qui a été fait car ce
sont aussi des personnes comme vous et
moi qui ont fait preuve d' arrêter en
accueillant des personnes chez elles des
centres d'accueil ont été ouverts
rapidement donc jusqu'ici effectivement
ne pourront que celle du cse d'arrêter
les considérant que cet afflux ne cesse
de grandir et encore une fois que tout à
fait compréhensible bien évidemment il
est important aussi de faire en sorte
que ce soit d'autres pays européens qui
prennent également le relais pour qu'on
puisse effectivement avoir un accueil
digne de ces personnes peut-être dans un
bain tout le long terme à propos
justement attaqué on va écouter ce que
disait à ce qu'en disait à l'instant le
ministre français de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin on se retrouve juste après
cécile coutrillons nous allons donner
jeudi prochain et espérons le nous
allons voter la protection temporaire à
tous les ukrainiens qui arriveront en
europe c'est-à-dire l'asile à tous les
européens tous les ukrainiens qui arrive
en salles voilà l'asile à tous les
ukrainiens qui arriveront en europe est
ce que c'est une mesure qui peut faire
l'unanimité au sein des vingt-sept ans
tout comme une espérons vivement c'est
bien évidemment l'une de nos
recommandations ne s'agit pas
aujourd'hui de tergiverser cergy
fragments de faire cet accueil en
urgence je le répète car c'est très
important nous avons eu donc des retours
sur le profilage ethnique est absolument
inadmissible
nous avons aussi entendu des propos
absolument choquant y compris en france
certains litoria liste en disant que
bien évidemment on peut accueillir dix
ukrainiens alors c'était très différent
ce qu'il s'agissait de syriens où
d'afghans dont c'est l'occasion pour
nous de rappeler aussi que le droit
d'asile est sacrée et la convention je
lève le protège et qui n'est hors de
question de procéder à de grosses houles
mans de réfugiés quel qu'il soit quand
c'est pour nous l'occasion de rappeler
que cette solidarité est absolument
indispensable
c'est à la fois un devoir légal est un
devoir moral qu'il soit ukrainien
afghans aussi rien merci beaucoup merci
cécile code rio d'avoir répondu ce matin
à nos questions